now absolutely level and hesitancy there
by alai finally decides to go to 86 with
his King and that black king is inching
closer because white wants to put that
Rook on the G file and trade the Rooks
off not allowed here if that Bishop it
snakes back here it comes if it gets to
F5 that white king could be an a mating
net back he's losing now he's in the net
he's in the net he walks right into the
net Bishop can you and they know it they
know it this is a well-known winning
position blacks Rook will come around
now and deliver a killer blow the white
King has no Escape squares any check on
the H file will be decisive Magnus goes
the long way around and white is stuck
ala with a smile he knows this is all
over he's gotten his King at the wrong
side there's a mate in one being
threatened that you cannot fight against
Magnus Carlson gets the job done takes
it to Armageddon alira is disappointed
he had this one a draw would have seen
him through and the other man who is
very relieved with this result is Hikaru
Nakamura you can defend for a long